good morning john i once witnessed two
women talking to each other about how
they can't help but judge other moms who
take their kids to mcdonald's and this
you know made me kind of mad it's not
the greatest injustice in the world but
come on
even leaving beside the fact that not
every mom has the same amount of money
and free time that you have
people understand the world differently
some people see fast food as a less
healthy but simple and tasty option
some people see it as cruel garbage that
they would never subject their children
to and like the reality is
fast food isn't good there are better
options for the environment and our
bodies but like we're all humans
experiencing the world differently so
make your fast food decisions and leave
the judgment out of it we're headed into
a part of this pandemic where things are
going to be less clear
sometime in the next month 25 of the
people in the u.s will be fully
vaccinated and a lot of them will be the
most at risk people sometime in the next
few months mask mandates are going to be
lifted even in places where the
governors aren't doing weird political
signaling to their base and i'm worried
about this stage of the pandemic being
pretty stressful what behavior becomes
okay when you're vaccinated what
behavior is okay when most people are
vaccinated who's gonna decide those
things and how are we going to judge
each other for our behavior and when we
do
judge each other what does that do for
our conception of our society
and each other here's the true thing the
goal of vaccines and behavioral changes
are the same and they are twofold one we
do these things so that the individual
doing
the thing doesn't get sick or gets less
sick but even more importantly number
two
the virus spreads more slowly because
there are fewer people shedding it that
second thing is the real goal of public
health advice
slowing the spread of the disease kicks
ass especially when every sick person
infects fewer than one other person
because that's when it stops
active exponential spread and instead
you just have little outbreaks and look
kovid isn't going away like maybe ever
but it will be much less of a problem in
places where lots of people give
vaccines and so i think i hope that we
will transition into it being less big
of a deal
and we're gonna have to decide for
ourselves what behaviors are okay
but to what extent are we gonna decide
also for other people
what behaviors are okay and a society
does have an acceptable disease burden
in the u.s
every year something like 30 000 people
die of flu
some of those people are infants and
children and we vaccinate and we tell
people to wash their hands and stay home
when they're sick but
we did all this stuff that we did before
with that situation now was that the
right thing to do
i don't know but we acted as if it was
every individual person's decisions
matter and different people will make
different decisions and people who are
more careful are going to average
the people who are less careful and
those behavioral changes will average
with the efficacy of the vaccine and the
result
will be the total disease burden so yes
people who are more careful
who are able to be more careful will be
helping the people who are less careful
whether that's because they can't be or
they don't want to be or because they've
bought into a different version
of reality than i have different people
are going to understand risk differently
they're going to understand citizenship
differently they're going to understand
societal impact differently and the
importance of behavior change is going
to slide out as the importance of the
vaccines
slide in as long as nothing goes
terribly wrong my advice what i'm gonna
do keep taking precautions i'm gonna
keep wearing a mask at the grocery store
when i'm fully vaccinated because
there's still a small chance i could
spread the disease but here's the point
i'm also really worried that we've all
spent a year cooped up looking at social
media where the average stranger you
hear about sucks pretty hard because
like strangers who don't suck
don't get turned into memes plus we're
exiting four years of having a president
whose favorite pastime was
fanning the flames of anger and
frustration with each other and now we
have this symbol
of how we understand the world literally
strapped to our face
or not and i'm worried about in myself
and in other people the judgment and
frustration that's going to come with
seeing people acting differently than i
would act
especially with our new seemingly higher
than ever skepticism about whether or
not our neighbors are good people i feel
like that takes
like an existing wound of judgment and
frustration and skepticism about
the the goodness of humans in our
society and
makes that wound deeper and harder to
heal i don't really want to play that
game but also i'm not sure
i can stop myself so that's just a thing
i'm worried about
jon i'll see you on tuesday